So if
someone were to tell me that I'm fired
from Marvel movies,
I will feel proud of what we made.
And yeah, so that's how I feel about it.
Do you stay up at night?
Missing her. Missing Wanda?
No, I don't.
I think it's been almost ten years
of playing her, and I've loved it.
I think the reason why I am not, like,
calling Kevin Feige,
like, every day with ideas is because I'm
really proud of what we were able to do.
I think Wandavision was really surprising
And I really am
just trying to figure out how to load up
other films and characters so it becomes
less about the marvel of it all.
Welcome back everyone
Some of you just started asking me
about this
Scarlet Witch news you've been seeing.
Some websites recently started reporting
that Marvel had fired her for some reason
and she was outed Scarlet Witch.
I'll explain what I think
is really going on with her character,
because that is one of the most ridiculous
things that I've ever heard,
What's your storyline for one Gun?
Do you want Well, honestly,
if I were to tell you
exactly what I would one, I think I would
maybe be spoiling something because
Heaven Fire genuinely asks
us what we want to do with the character,
and then he does it.
So I think what?
I don't know if I can share,
but I just want to come back.
Marvel will be doing a lot a lot
of Scarlet Witch stuff in the future.
Movies with some specific Disney
Plus series.
I'll explain what that is,
because there's a very clearly defined
plan for Scarlet Witch going forward.
If you're new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
So I was totally caught off guard recently
when some of you started
sending me website articles
saying Elizabeth Olsen had been fired.
My immediate thought was
it was total crap.
Kevin Feige was quoted literally
just saying that he'd work with her
for another hundred years,
like he went for Rick and Morty
rant on Elizabeth Olsen as Scarlet Witch.
This is literally what he said.
and this is me
paraphrasing Kevin Feige talks about his plans
with the Scarlet Witch after Doctor
Strange multiverse of Madness.
She's incredibly humble
and incredibly down to earth.
And yet when those cameras roll,
it's a force of nature.
And what about Wanda?
There's really so much more to explore,
he says.
We still haven't touched many of her core
storylines from the comics
lot of X-Men stuff that they have
coming up in the next several years, leads
to say all of her storylines with Billy
and Tommy when they come back as adults.
when people took Kevin Feige to task
about what really happened
at the end of Doctor
Strange Multiverse Man is like,
Did you really get crushed
under that building?
the way he talked about
it was very ironic.
Like, I don't know what we actually saw
under the rubble.
Did we actually see her body?
I saw a tower coming down in a red flash.
So I don't know what that's supposed to
mean.
Obviously, he knows what it means.
sending a pretty clear signal
to all the Elizabeth Olsen
stands out there
if you don't see your body.
Cardinal rule of comics
is that they're definitely not dead.
And sometimes if you do see a body,
like in the case of Vision during Avengers
Infinity War, they can still totally
come back in white vision.
Kevin Feige then ended by saying
I'd worked with Lizzie for another hundred
years.
Ending by saying anything is possible
in the multiverse.
honestly, I don't think he needed
to provide the multiverse qualifier.
Like literally
she could come back in any number of ways.
now that interview with him was before
they announced their plans for Agatha
Coven of Chaos.
Which characters will be back for Avengers
5 Kang Dynasty, four Secret Wars.
So there was a lot of stuff
they hadn't announced yet.
Saying what they were going to do
with Billy and Tommy
because they were always going
to bring back
adult versions of those characters
no matter what.
the reason why I think these crazy rumors
about her being fired,
which I definitely think are false,
I think why they started
because one website just posted an article
about like a bad joke that someone made,
maybe like a four can joke
without knowing that it was a joke
when I read their article
to some of the evidence that they cited,
just didn't make sense.
Like, well,
they're releasing a bunch of Blu rays
for the Marvel Disney Plus shows,
but they didn't announce
one division,
so they're obviously going to fire her.
That just didn't make sense because
they are releasing a one division Blu ray.
They're just releasing it
right after the Loki one.
Then I think that thing happened
where a bunch of other websites
just site this one initial website.
So the rumor just starts spreading.
Even though it's complete nonsense.
sometimes there are
rumors like that just start out in really
weird places that do wind up being true.
Like all the Deadpool three cameo scenes,
the majority of those reports are true.
Not all of them, but some of them.
Usually I try to wait at least a few days
when I hear stuff like this
just to see if some other legit websites
are reporting stuff,
then you actually know
it might be a thing Right now, the next
big Scarlet Witch stories Marvel is
planning to do are an Agatha coven.
Of course,
a lot of that plot is tied to
what just happened
with Scarlet Witch
in the consequences of that.
And Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
they're bringing back
an adult version of Billy.
The explanation for how he comes back in
the MCU will be different
for how he came back in the comics
because it was really,
really twisty in the comics
and didn't even make that much sense.
They were kind of all over the map
on that.
same thing for Tommy coming back to,
but just Billy is coming back
during Agatha Coven of Chaos is going to
be played by Joe Locke from Heart Supper.
You probably seen a bunch of fan art
that series is mostly going to be Agatha
trying to protect Billy
from another coven of witches.
It sounds like Aubrey Plaza's character,
who's supposed to be
the main villain, will be leading them.
They haven't said officially
who she's playing, but is reported
that she's going to be like a brand new
character based on some comic book tropes
the name they're going with
is Reno Vidal in They're calling her
the first green witch in the MCU.
Normally when people think of Green Witch
in Marvel,
they're thinking of the Enchantress.
But she's not playing
a version of the Enchantress.
any time
there's like a brand new Thor movie
or a brand new Loki project,
people keep asking,
Do you think they're going
to enchantress in this one?
especially when Loki season one
was coming out.
So many people had theories that Sylvie
would wind up being enchantress,
but they did base some of her character
on Enchantress, though
that's why some of her abilities
are a little bit different
from Loki's abilities.
during Coven of Chaos.
They're supposedly saying that during
Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
Scarlet Witch's Chaos, Magic Powers
transported her to the Witches
Road just as the Darkhold
Temple was collapsing on her.
that's what the flash of red
light was meant to be.
It was her chaos.
Magic powers automatically protecting her
by taking her to this alternate universe
They got into this place
the witches rode in.
The newer Scarlet Witch comic is meant
to be like an alternate plane of existence
that only other Sorcerers
magic users can go to.
And she's been there since the events
of Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness.
There were a couple of reports early
on that we might see
the 838 universe Scarlet Witch again,
and Elizabeth Olsen
will be back to play her
in Deadpool three.
Some of those rumors got shot
down, though,
but the entire plot of Deadpool
three does revolve around
what happens next in the A38 universe.
After Multiverse of Madness.
I've already done
a ton of videos about that.
I literally just posted another Deadpool
three video,
so I'll link those at the end of this
and down to the description below
because it is going to be crazy
the next really big Scarlet Witch story.
After that will be her returning
for real in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty.
Like they're not going to do an Avengers
movie benching
one of the most powerful characters
they have in the MCU.
That would be ridiculous.
then when Kevin Feige was teasing,
doing more of her comic book stories, her
core stories that they hadn't
gotten to yet, he was talking
mostly about X-Men mutants, crossover,
dealing with the magneto of it all.
more stories with her children, Billy
and Tommy Generally, just expect to see
way more Scarlet Witch in X-Men crossovers
in the next several years.
Not just the movies,
but also the animated stuff.
Probably in the comics too,
because Elizabeth Olsen
is also supposed to come back in the new
What if season two season
as her version of Scarlet Witch?
whispering the words
No more attacks I'm not totally sure.
But there might also be Scarlet
Witch inside X-Men 97, Season one,
maybe season two,
because Scarlet Witch was referenced
during the original X-Men,
the animated series.
there was also talk a couple of years ago
about them doing a Scarlet Witch
solo movie.
And that might have changed,
but at the time they would have used that
to cover all of the important Lord
that they hadn't got to in the comics,
like adult Billy and Tommy coming back.
Scarlet Witch is relationship to Magneto,
her untold history with Kathleen,
the God of Chaos
that's probably one of the biggest holes
that they have just brushed
over in the movie so far
like oh yeah, here's all this law, here's
this Darkhold temple.
It was created by stone, the God of Chaos.
He's the person that also created
the Darkhold.
He's the reason
why you have your chaos magic.
And then they just kind of brushed over it
In the comics, Katan is the God of chaos.
He's the person who gave Scarlet Witch
or Chaos Magic when she was born.
he's one of the ancient elder
gods of the MCU that was expelled
from the main dimension a long time ago
and has been trying to break back in
ever since and tries to backdoor
you Scarlet Witch in the darkhold
to do that,
all those references to her
becoming the Scarlet Witch
and ruling over the multiverse in
the movie
were meant to be a sly reference to that.
it was all about Cauthen trying to use her
to take over the entire multiverse.
as for vision.
I don't think that they had plans
to get the two of them back together
in the future.
Elizabeth Olsen
just made it sound like in interviews
emotionally she felt like White
Vision was a totally different person
from her vision
and was going to focus in the MCU
going forward just on her children.
That was kind of the joke during Doctor
Strange
Multiverse of Madness,
like what was going on with 838 vision?
Where was he at pull out
all those old Wandavision means
so relevant now me and Wanda,
we don't talk no more.
They're giving White Vision,
the Vision Quest series.
I'll do more videos about it
when they reveal more information.
He might come back during the Iron Man
Armor War series because we'll see Ultron
come back during that.
And he's
so tied to the Ultron character,
it makes sense
that they'd face each other again
at some point let me know in the comments.
What do you want them to do with Scarlet
Witch's character going forward?
I know most people would just be like
more X-Men crossovers.
We want to see more X-Men stuff.
We want to see more Scarlet Witch
with the X-Men,
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Loki Season two episodes starting October
after the Asoka episodes.
I'm doing videos for all that stuff
weekly.
Make sure to enable alerts from my channel
so you don't miss that.
Click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 video and click here
to learn about Doctor Strange 3.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!